foreign
there are no journalistic institutions
that function but there are some
journalists who still function right
Sagar
mataibi Glenn Greenwald cyhurst right
um these are all people who could
potentially see the big picture and
start following it and because they're
supported by comparatively independent I
don't know inside Hershey's case but in
the other cases I mentioned they're
supported by their audiences they could
potentially
um stare down what will come back at
them right but they're going to have to
remember their skepticism they're going
to have to remember the conflicts of
interest that sources have and they're
going to have to you know ignore bad
evidence no matter where bad information
no matter how authoritatively it's
dressed
um because journalism functions as you
know one of very few checks on political
and economic power and it is obvious
that whatever it is that has taken over
our system is sort of loosely in the
neighborhood of political and economic
power right we don't know what it is but
we can see what it does
um
and you know
certainly
I would say certainly the place to start
and the place
as you point out the
source of the virus is somehow more
explorable than the other questions
surrounding covet right
we did surprisingly well on that topic
because people I think probably
misunderstand how much still rests on on
the question
um
but at the point that
some journalist or some set of
journalists starts pursuing this
they're going to have to recognize that
you know if we can go back to the entire
diagnosis of the system right
we are living in something that is
functioning like uh
a Dark Age
we have to figure out because much rests
on I mean look let's let's talk about
the question of the the origin of the
virus more directly
if the virus
came from nature without human meddling
right if it came through the wet Market
because somebody brought a wild animal
there that had the virus and it jumped
to people and created the pandemic then
that suggests as we've discussed before
on Dark Horse
that those who were rapidly working
their way towards understanding these
potentially pandemic viruses weren't
fast enough right we didn't fund them
enough we didn't do enough gain of
function research right whereas if this
escaped from the lab then the exact
opposite is true right if this is the
result of our gain of function research
program to study these viruses that were
argued to be potentially pandemic
starting an argument that I think was
way overdrawn because jumping from
nature across species barriers is far
harder than they represented it
um but if it turns out to have come from
the lab then the point is this is
entirely a self-inflicted wound the
whole pandemic right and so everything
hangs on that question and it has to be
nailed down it cannot be
I mean I feel like we're looking at the
tobacco Industries Playbook right of
trying to muddle the evidence right
trying to make it impossible to figure
out what's true so most people will
simply move on and the point is how much
damage has this done I mean even if
covet were to disappear tomorrow
the disruption of our global system
right the inability of Supply chains to
function the fact that we have you know
labor shortages that make certain
essential processes uh completely
unreliable right that is all Downstream
of this one question so it has to be
studied and likewise
the the issue of
let's take for example
the health consequence of the one remedy
that was pushed on everyone yeah
this is not a difficult question
right it is a noisy question right
there's plenty of statistical noise in
the impact of a particular remedy that
was administered to billions of people
but it is a question that science is
well positioned to answer relatively
easily we can't say what the consequence
of those inoculations will be for people
decades in
but we should have a rapidly
accumulating body of evidence that says
what is the effect when you're at what
is the effect three years out right that
body of evidence should be accumulating
and we should be getting smarter as a
result of it right this is something our
University this is this is the shallow
end of the pool from the point of view
of logic and study this isn't
technically difficult this isn't
statistically difficult this is
something what you need is to compare
groups and these you need to have large
enough samples that you address the the
question of noise and you figure out
what the signal is it should be easily
done and again we're looking at
something
that is apparently not interested in the
answer to that question
which I think then
it it leaves us at the following
um
uncomfortable end point
which is
if our system
is not interested in figuring out now
what the consequences of Its Behavior
were
that means that it is indifferent
to the suffering and death of
millions of people
if it is indifferent to the suffering
and death of millions of people now
it is at least strongly possible that it
was indifferent from the beginning that
it wasn't ever especially interested in
protecting people it was interested in
doing something else that has never been
shared with us
and so I think we have to ask
in light of the obvious evidence of
cover-up that we've seen the cover-up of
the connection to the Wuhan lab the
cover-up in fauci's emails the cover-up
of the harm to healthy young people who
never should have been advised to get
these inoculations in the first place we
have to ask the question what did The
Architects of this policy know
and when did they know it right it's a
traditional journalistic question you
have to follow the money and we have to
know what did they know and when did
they know it and I will point out that
there are certain things
which would be decisive if we understood
them
for example
did these people
when they got covered
have access to repurposed drugs that
they claim didn't work or didn't they
what did they have access but did they
use did they use did they Avail
themselves of drugs that they advised
others not to use
did they get the vaccinations did they
get the same ones that other people got
did they get particular ones right or
didn't they right what did they know and
when did they know it and I'm not
claiming that we can access that
information that we can discover and I'm
not claiming to know but I think the
point is
we've seen enough evidence that the
trials revealed hazards of these
inoculations
that
it's not obvious that the people who
push them hardest
got the same shots as other people got
and
um a journalist should pursue that that
information because if they didn't then
that would tell us that actually this
was not a massive error that has been
followed up by the indifference of these
people that it was in fact in fact
indifference to the suffering and death
of uh strangers that existed from the
beginning
[Music]